welcome to this video playing to
Grandma's the doctor from Russia I
forgot I forgot the name forgot his name
I had it looked it up Alexander cousin
yeah it looked it up just a couple of
days ago because I played him before e3
yeah we have the Trump here and this is
the Snyder 64 is the recommendation of
grand master Boris a brook in his um d
for sidelines book it's basically
transposing to learn to a Londoner
system where black has lost the temple
but is but he argues that this London
setup is so harmless that you could
easily play it with the tempo down okay
well like this certainly if you look at
the concrete game position black
certainly does not experience any
particular problems okay so it tries to
get something going along the e4 eh
diagonal yeah I think I probably should
give up this Bishop before he comes with
95 and now just complete development
yeah white white got the bishop but this
is not not so decisive in this position
yeah if I really want i can play 98 and
Ted rid of the bishop pair on night h5
but this is only a bit yeah it can do
that why not i mean it's certainly
simplifying yeah come on let's get rid
of this age for bishop and stop this
worried that the bishop pair might be a
factor yeah i probably will just take it
seven yeah all this one is it is there a
problem and why no I don't think so
Queen g4 maybe I can still take you can
take h5 now and then expertise it
doesn't ready it doesn't really have a
look too threatening yeah now with the
dark squared bishop gone the knight on
f6 is a very useful piece providing some
color for the king and supporting
central play it cannot be arrest in any
way yeah will be for some about the only
play that he has
I prepare your fourth ah that's an
interesting move but addy for more d phi
sky before i'm not sure that i should
should allow that but i can just take if
I like why not just them just simplify
yeah yeah that's no reason not to yeah
well a sexy will take this is something
that I must be a big gorgeous about I
can play a rook c8 down on Bishop b5 for
half 97 it's just a position you need to
play some precise defensive moves and
then it should be okay King e7 maybe
Bishop f4 I go night e 7 and they can
play work T 1
Kim
I forgot about that one
it's not the end of the world but um
okay well it's still nothing nothing
special
wow I thought you would at least take on
c6 I mean this is just absolutely
nothing
okay 97 rookie one that's a little trick
yeah b5 yeah it's on a light square but
still there's absolutely nothing going
on check check hmm downfall you can try
to gain some space of course but they
don't think it it's really really any
any substantial danger yeah just I think
you overlooked before books III before
no I'm just better
h 5 p.m. the sun is something to be
cautious about but i'll push be three be
three is a big threat be three followed
by 94 check check let's see what's the
best way to play that rook a one look in
193 problem i just got this chick forgot
about the check hmm
yeah that's a shame I forgot about this
bloody check hi morning check check
check yeah yeah this was simply I was
simply too slow but can you save the
whole game I'm just winning like I'm
just I'm just running if I'm have just
one second increment in this game yeah
yeah yeah hey Gus it's counterplay and
then it was just a matter of concrete
tactics I forgot that yes rook da dive
thought I can play king evade and I
cannot simply and this means or this
meant that I had to retreat the rook and
it wasn't so clear door around here it's
just a matter of one or two priests a
smooth and he just resins be too for
example it's just winning here look III
can simply resign after that check and
here resins that's it yeah yeah that
this this is the last how to play and
about the only threat you had in the old
game basically this is still clearly
better from like but I it's it's
difficult to check to play with 15
seconds on the clock I am probably round
here I can I can play it play it better
yeah be one Queen here this is this is
this
the move that probably still wins though
it's tricky now it's two against one but
I have Brooke age 2 is probably still
winning for black yeah well okay it was
I spend too much time simply because I
was worried about stuff he didn't play I
mean to be honest taking on d7 here is
just completely insane why why would you
do that and I take this is just the
clearly better move the at least this
gives some slight chances 97 is just
just nothing and the only motivation to
play this position for widest to hope
for ki pole into fall asleep or
something check then am check and then
you blundered into into this simple
thing alright thanks for watching